- [Mark] All right, Sleepy.
Sleepy, how'd you get the name Sleepy?
- I have 16 brothers and when my brothers
were playing with me at school,
he made me scratch my arm
and when I got out, I socked him
and I knocked him out
and ever since then I got the name Sleepy.
- [Mark] That's great.
That's a great day for you then.
Where'd you grow up?
- I'm born in New Orleans.
I was raised in Watts.
That was a hard part of life.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I been to jail.
I've been to prison.
I sold dope.
I done cut folks.
I done shot at folks.
I have a big problem with assault.
I have a seven years assault case
where I stabbed and shot my husband.
Cheating.
So, and my biggest thing
is, relationships, hey,
that's not good for me,
'cause I take my relationships seriously.
So, I've been to prison twice.
- [Mark] What for?
- For assault.
- Mm-hmm.
- The first one, it was
close to attempted murder,
but he lived, so it was assault.
It dropped down to assault.
Hey, I done shot motherfuckers.
It's nothing to be proud of,
but you know what I mean, hey,
when you grow up like this,
I've been on the street ever
since I was 13 years old.
So, when you have to grow
up by the street life,
hey, it's survival, you know what I mean?
A lot of people don't understand that.
It's like you could change your lifestyle.
But for me, I got 16 brothers,
so I felt like I ain't had
no sisters to depend on.
So, I grew up rough.
- [Mark] Tell me about your childhood.
You grew up with both parents?
- I have 16 brothers.
There's two of us, I'm a twin,
but my mother wasn't never around,
so the boys was always around,
so I grew up with the rough boys.
- [Mark] Where was your mom?
- Now my mom is dead.
- [Mark] No, where was
she when you were a kid?
- Oh, at work all the time.
- [Mark] So she was working.
- And doing pills and drugs,
so I'm raised around drugs, pills, jobs.
- [Mark] So your mom was an addict then?
- Yes.
- [Mark] And where's dad?
- What?
- [Mark] Where was your dad?
- Oh, my dad, he was my stepfather,
he wasn't my dad.
My daddy's in New Orleans.
My stepfather when he was here, he worked.
My mom tried to sell me
to the dope man for drugs.
- For sex?
- Mm-hmm.
- [Mark] At what age?
- What? My sold me to the dope man?
I was what, 11.
I lived in my mama house when I was 13.
I turned my first trick
when I was 14 years old
and I left my mom house and I been
on the streets ever since.
I just recently went, eight years ago,
I had got in a relationship.
He just recently died,
but he knew about my past,
so we had a relationship where
it was a space between us
in our relationship and I appreciate him,
but my kids' father, it
tried to kill him, twice.
I did seven years behind my kids' father.
I cut him, hey, cut him
in front the police.
I didn't give a fuck about the police.
I'm serious, I didn't care
and it was a rough life for me.
You know what I mean?
And since I've been, I waited until
I was 52 years old to get an ID
to get my shit together.
I just recently got into a shelter
since I've been older,
but I've been to prison twice,
one for possession and
assault on a police officer.
When I was in prison I
had 115s still are pending
on me in prison.
I mean, serious 115s where
I done hit the police
and I look at it now where it says
I can change my lifestyle.
It's not cool.
And I wish a lot of people
would really sit down.
I have changed people life
where people done got their shit together.
I have a home boy right now,
I'm a part of his story
where he used to be a dope
fiend, a dope dealer, jacker.
He done put me in two or three programs.
I done left the program,
beat up people in the program.
Assaults in the program.
A really bad lifestyle.
Hey, I'm quick with a temper.
I'm very smart with the mouth.
But it's not cool, it's not really cool.
And I try to catch some of
these young people out here
to tell them hey, the
lifestyle that you living,
change it while you got a chance
'cause it's nothing out there.
It's bullshit, and if they really knew.
I'm 52 years old.
I have nine kids.
I didn't raise none of my kids.
- [Mark] You have grandkids?
- I have nine.
I have grandkids, too.
- [Mark] Who raised them?
- My kids, my family and everything.
Hey, the pen is nothing for
a motherfucker to live at.
They almost gave me a life sentence
behind an officer that I actually cut,
but then they found out
that she was provoking.
Wanted to bully me and
I wasn't fixing to go
for the bully shit, you
know what I'm saying?
- [Mark] So you're saying
you can be violent,
but you need to be provoked first?
- What?
- [Mark] Somebody needs to push you.
- Push you but really, yeah.
But other than that,
I'm more like I can put
up with the bullshit,
but when you provoking me
to like trying to pump me, like,
hey, he know I'm quick to, you know.
But for a woman, I ignore them
'cause they more or less harmful to me,
but a man, I'll go with a man quicker
than I will a woman
because that's all I was raised around.
That's exactly how I got my assault cases.
It's never been really too many on women.
It's been more on men.
I have a nephew down here
that's losing fingers behind me.
I cut his fingers off.
God forgive me for that, for real.
I don't play that.
So, I'm not allowed to have no kind
of weapons in my pocket.
I'm not even allowed to have a razor blade
in my pocket.
You know the toenail clippers
with the little file thing,
I'm not allowed to have that in my pocket.
I'm not allowed to have
no kind of like chemical
that's flammable in my possession.
You know what I mean?
Hey, exactly I'm just,
I'll say it like this,
weapon wise I'm not allowed
to have things like that
in my pocket, a battery in my pocket
because I still could use that
as a weapon.
- [Mark] So were you in a
gang when you were younger?
- [Sleepy] Mm-hmm.
- [Mark] Which gang?
- [Sleepy] In two or three gangs.
I was in the Main Streets,
I was in the Bounty Hunters,
I was in the Grapes,
my son is from Grapes,
I was in there.
- Grape Shape?
- Mm-hmm.
- [Sleepy] 10 Lines.
That's how I got shot in the mouth.
I been shot, I been stabbed.
It's actually for a girl
life style like that,
hey, I'm blessed to even, you
know what I mean, say hey,
I'm here to tell a story.
- [Mark] Are you using drugs still or?
- I ain't gonna lie.
Yeah, I still smoke crack.
I put it to a certain limit.
I smoke weed.
I mostly now try to drink and smoke weed,
trying to put that behind me.
Hey, life is hard for me.
I'm the baby out of 18,
so I'm the black sheep.
- [Mark] Do you still talk to your kids?
- Oh, I see my kids all the time.
If I don't talk to them on the phone,
I have six that's in New Orleans
and I have three.
My youngest is 13
and she's taller than me,
but I thank God for her because
she done caused me some
of my life's (indistinct).
I think this time I'd be really in prison
for life behind her if
I wouldn't have had her.
When I found out I was pregnant,
I had quit smoking dope for a minute.
I quit being rowdy.
I stopped trying to hurt people.
I say it like this.
She is the cause of me
changing my lifestyle.
Actually I didn't give
a fuck about no police
and still don't really.
I don't like the police.
Me and him done had some crashes,
some serious crashes
where hey, he done tried
to hurt me and I done tried to kill him
and that's why he keeps saying,
and then after that, I got soft.
But, hey, if a motherfucker
really wanna know
about prison, that's no place to be.
That's not a lifestyle that you wanna keep
and if you ever come out of prison,
hey, pass it down to
somebody that haven't,
hey, there's other things you can do
than to harm and hurt people,
'cause prison, that will keep you,
how they say it crazy on the other end.
'Cause they were gonna have me admitted
to the crazy house
after I got outta prison
because of my husband.
If I seen him on site, I would stick him.
He didn't even have to say
nothing, I would stick him.
For some reason I just
wanted to hurt him bad.
And that's not my life no more.
So I go to church now.
I gave my life to God.
I still get high,
but it ain't like where I really,
I wanna quit everything.
- [Mark] Good for you.
- Yeah.
- Great.
- [Mark] Thank you for talking to me.
- Mm-hmm.
- I appreciate it.